today's question comes from Christopher
and Oklahoma for the past six years I've
been going in circles making purchases
on the credit card I'd pay it off the
same thing happens again last year I got
myself into $1,500 worth of debt seems
like I can never pay it off because more
data crews like medical and dentist
bills and eats up my money I'd like to
move forward but I'm paralyzed by this I
feels like I'm working like crazy
fanatically running in circles like a
chicken with my head cut off
a tired hamster in a wheel and man we've
all had that feeling so there's a saying
that 12-steppers have Christopher if you
keep doing the same thing over and over
again and expect a different result
that's the definition of insanity and so
let your frustration with the situation
rise to the level you get pissed off
enough to do something about it and
change you have to change my friend Les
Brown the great motivator says people
change their lives only when they
finally say I've had it I'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired that's
when you change people didn't change
this just to difficult people will do
the same thing we all do we drive the
same way to work we sit the same place
in church
well do the same thing over and over and
over and over and over again I've been
wearing the same pair of blue jeans for
ten years I mean we just don't change we
don't change we'll keep doing the same
old stuff and wonder why things aren't
changing because we hadn't changed it
all but man if you get mad enough if you
get sick and tired of being sick and
tired and you finally say I've had it
that's when you change now what would
you do if you got that mad you'd start
selling stuff you take an extra job
you'd actually get on a budget and you'd
write out a budget and then you'd
actually live on the budget you'd get
the every dollar app it's free and do
outlay out your game plan it takes ten
minutes you go here where's my money
going a budgets people telling their
money where to go instead of wondering
where it went
you'd sell stuff you'd have you take the
Tahoe you
up the stupid credit cards and vow to
never use them again but as long as
there's not enough pain to activate you
to change you'll probably just sit in
the slop of mediocrity so the
interesting thing is you can just decide
one minute later to be pissed off that's
when things changed I was a little kid a
little redneck hillbilly kid we run in
and out of the house all the
neighborhood kids running in our house
running out of the house running out of
the house letting all the air
conditioning go out yelling screaming
running through the house like wild
crazy people finally after a while my
mother would have enough y'all know I'm
talking about where Mama's have enough
she'd say that's it the worm has turned
now we had no idea what that meant
except the beatings were getting ready
to begin that's all we were sure of the
worm has turned
turns out as Shakespeare who knew mom
knew Shakespeare but there you go and
the worm has turned
it's over I'm doing that's it I've had
it no more and you gotta have that
moment that's when people lose weight
that's when their marriages get better
that's when their crazy wild children
straighten up that's it I've had it you
suddenly start putting up boundaries you
no longer have people taking advantage
of you you leave a toxic situation but
it's a decision isn't it it's
interesting you can just wake up and
decide to say that and mean it nothing
really physically has to change no
circumstances has to change the only
thing that changes is between your two
ears that little six-inch space there
and you go you know what I have a choice
I get to choose my dignity I'm not gonna
live like this anymore and that's when
people get out of debt that's when they
get on a budget and that's when their
friends who have not become disgusted
with our mediocre lives make fun of them
and that's what's going on you just got
to reach that point though that that's
it I'm done it's a great moment by the
way and it's happened to me several
times in my life at on different
subjects
I mean spiritually it's when I fell on
my face before God and said Jesus I
accept you as my Lord and Savior
that was an I've had it moment that's a
spiritual moment right and changing
things I don't use the words I used to
work uses adjectives I don't treat
people the way I used to treat people if
I want to lay down RL stupids a cuss
word let's say you didn't grow up where
I did darling but you have it I've had
it moment I change it's called it's
called repentance you change direction
you change direction it's a 180 I'm
walking one way I'm driving down the
interstate the wrong direction and you
go crap and go the wrong way and you get
off the exit go under the bridge take a
left and get back on going the right way
and the little lady in your phone will
tell you that you have done the right
thing in her little passive-aggressive
voice I still think they ought to
program those phones with your wife's
voice but I don't want to I know but
anyway yeah hang around I mean seriously
you know what happens when you get off
the interstate and turn and go back the
other way
you have changed if you were driving 70
miles an hour you have changed the
direction of your life at 140 miles an
hour
you're no longer going 70 the wrong way
now you're going 70 the right way that's
a delta of 140 that's what happens when
you say I've had it and Christopher I
think that's in your future my man I
love it